in the war in Ukraine Russia launched
more missiles and drones overnight
killing at least 10 people there and
injuring dozens in one Ukrainian City
Ukraine says Russia is trying to take
attention away from its recent losses on
the front lines Ian Lee has the latest
on the overnight attacks
overnight deadly Russian missiles and
drones rained down on the heart of
Ukraine one hitting this apartment
building in Creve while people were
sleeping firefighters battled The Blaze
into the morning now Rescuers searched
for the missing and the dead
the First Bank woke me up and I went
straight to my balcony says this witness
the second explosion roared over my head
as hot debris fell and I saw the
building on fire
the latest attack comes as Ukraine's
counter-offensive slowly pushes forward
Ukrainian troops fiercely fight for
every mile forcing the Russians back
so far officials say they've recaptured
at least seven settlements
but it comes at a price Russia has
destroyed Western supplied equipment
including German tanks and American
armored fighting Vehicles the heavy toll
also paid by civilians
fled from solidar they show us their
apartment now a burnt out shell we have
no home Tatiana tells me who knows where
we'll live on the street
tears aren't in short supply here they
also have family members missing you
haven't heard anything from them you
don't know where they are we don't know
where they are she tells me we pray
we'll find them and also that will find
some place to live in peace
a piece many ukrainians hope will be won
by this offensive
Ukraine is still asking for further
heavy Weaponry a pentagon official tells
CBS News the White House will announce a
new 325 million dollar Aid package later
today that'll include more of those
Bradley and Striker armored fighting
Vehicles Tony
Ian Lee forest in Ukraine Ian thank you
very much